our economic system in its current form
is simply not advanced enough to
comprehend the consequences of its own
actions it is like a blind jayant
lumbering from continent to continent
leaving incalculable ruin in its wake I
propose we give this giant a set of eyes
so that it might tread more gently and
maybe someday even look upon itself the
CEO of today will be judged not only by
how well we change our industries but
also about how well we lead our
companies to make positive impacts when
choosing a leader you choose on the
behavior and what because it will did
she choked with the example today I let
the way in which we are growing things
the way in which we are making products
providing services is having an
unexpected and disastrous impact on the
planet that we live on we need to change
in attitudes and new institutions to set
the right incentives so that what the
use becomes more efficient across the
world everybody who takes action
actually has an effect on sat at least
somebody and obviously the more power
the more influential about the bigger
the impact there can be across the world
it's not less been working together it's
new ideas it's creating new concepts and
it's happening while we speak it will
challenge the way we think it will
challenge the way we work and it will
challenge the way we work with artists
there needs to be a more equal division
between the company owner and the
employee please take full responsibility
for your actions and your in actions and
leave a nice legacy for our children and
our grandchildren extend hands and
overcome obstacles to make open trades
and exchange of ideas and the exchange
of cultures and the change of people
easier in 2008 which certainly helped
make the planet a better place
you